Blueprint interfaces are a way to efficiently communicate with various
blueprints throughout your project without having to load the entire
blueprint into memory. Now with our particular project it's relatively small
so this introduction to blueprint interfaces is to do just that and to
introduce you to blueprint interfaces because as your project grows in
complexity these are going to be very very important to your project success. So
to create them what we do is we come over to the content browser and we right
click we look for the blueprint category and then we select our
interface. Inside the interface it's going to look very familiar to a
blueprint graph but the big difference is that it's going to say
read only across the top here and we're only going to be able to actually
add inputs and outputs but for our case what we're going to be doing is we're
going to create a new blueprint interface and we are going to add two
inputs to it a score and a time and that way we can more easily pass these
values around to our interface and our car and things like that so let's pop
over to the editor and do this right now so I'm actually going to close this
I'm going to hit control space and I'm going to navigate up to our content
folder right click we're going to go to blueprint and add a blueprint
interface. Now I like to call mine VPI for blueprint interface we're to call
this I think vehicle all right and then let's double click on it to open it up
now once you have it open we have a new function so we're going to right
click on this and rename it to picked up objects and then what we're going
to do is under our inputs we're going to add one and two and we're going to
call this one score and we're going to call the other one time we also need to
change these from Booleans to integer values so there we go both sets
integers and once we're done we do need to compile and save what we need
to do after that is we need to assign this blueprint interface to the
blueprint we wish to work with in our case that's going to be the BPP sports
car so what we're going to do is we're going to come back over here to the
editor we're going to hit ctrl space we're going to go look for our
blueprints and then we're going to go a sports car and there's our BPP
sports car so that's the one that we want right there you double click on
it to open it up and to add a interface we come over to our class
settings and then under our interfaces you can see we have this
implemented interfaces right now we have no interfaces so what we're going to do
is we're going to go to add and then from the search we're going to type in
BPI and that's going to bring everything down a little bit easier for
us to navigate and there's our BPI vehicle so we're going to click on
that and compile and save now once we've done that we are going to now
create the following bit of code so what we're going to do is event
picked up objects we're going to get the current score we're going to set
the current score and then we're going to cast to our game mode to get the
time remaining and then set the time remaining and this is going to set up the
logic for us to work with our pickups so to do this what we're going to do here
is we're going to come over to our BP sports car
we do need to add some variables so we're going to add one
and two and this first one we're going to right click and we're going to
rename this one to current score
and actually we don't need the second one right now we're actually just going
to delete that so also need to change our current score
to a integer and compile and save so that we can use it so let's go ahead
and just move somewhere off to the side here and what we're
going to do now is we're going to look for our
event picked up and there we go event picked up objects and what are we
going to do with this well for our we need to get
our current score so we're going to grab this
and we're going to go get because we want to get the current value of that
so let's set up our score and then our time so we're going to take our score
we're going to hit the plus sign here and we're going to go utilities
operators add we're going to add these two
together right so we want to take our current
our score from the pickup here and then we want to add that to our
current score and then what we want to do is we want
to take our current score we're going to bring this out again and we're going
to go set current score and what we're
basically going to be doing is incrementing our score so as our
score updates we're going to take our current score we're going to add that to our score value
that comes in here and then update our current score again so basically we're going to iterate
on our current score and we're going to do something similar with the time remaining
so we're going to get game mode because remember our time is set up inside of our game
but we could have set the time up in here but it's better to set the time up inside of
the game mode and again remember our game is very small this is just good practice for how things
should be built inside of blueprints as your projects grow longer so what we're going to do
here is from this return value we are going to cast not gassed but cast to BP GM vehicle basic
there we go and we're also going to right click on this and convert this to a pure cast
and the difference is that basically a pure cast is assuming that we know exactly what we're doing
and the values that we are getting it's not going to involve any error checking so we're going to
right click on this convert to a pure cast and then what we're going to do here is we are going
to go time and we are going to get the time remaining so there we go and then from our time
here what we're going to do is we're going to hit the plus sign so we have an add operation
and basically again we're going to do something very similar here i'm going to actually double click
on this line to add what's known as a redirector to make this a little bit easier for us to see
but we're going to take our uh our from our game mode we are going to get our time remaining
and then we're going to take what the time remaining is and we are going to add that
to the time that comes in from our pickup and then what we're going to do here
is we are going to pull off of this set uh and we might be able to get this set
time nope what we're going to have to do is a pull off of here uh so we're going to pull off of this
and we're going to go set time and there we go set time remaining is the value that we are
looking for and what we want to do here is we want to grab from this set and plug in like so
and then we want to take the output of this addition and plug this in and i'm also going
to double click on these lines to clear this up so for some reason we have this extra node
here so let's just move that out of the way so there we go that is what we're looking at now
if you need a second or two to get caught up we're going to pause right here now before
we go into the next part which is a score and time pickup so this is all we have for
this part and when you are done you should have something that looks like this